Selena Gomez and Drew Taggart are
feeling all the feelings
[Music]
they love it a source sells E.T the
couple who sparked dating rumors earlier
this month are having a lot of fun
together I'm in a really happy place
quote Drew is really happy around Selena
and Selena is into Drew too you never
know who you're gonna make magic with so
our source adds that the pair has
connected over their love of Music can't
keep my hands to myself and being in the
same industry is a plus too
[Applause]
[Music]
appreciates that Selena understands his
life I'm really excited E.T confirmed
the singers are dating last month as for
how they met we're told it was through
mutual friends in a friendly low-key way
[Music]
from there it was an instant connection
and days later the two were spotted hand
in hand on a date night in New York City
despite their budding romance neither
have gone public with their relationship
in fact the day after their Dating News
broke cell shared she's still single I'm
very honest though in general in this
Instagram story she wrote I like being
alone too much hashtag I am single I
think it's nice to have a little bit
something to myself but we do know last
year she was on the hunt for love I'm
single and
and I've heard that SNL is a great place
to find romance since I don't really
want to try the dating apps I just want
to put it out in the universe that I'm
manifesting love and I would like to say
that I'm looking for my soulmate but at
this point I will take anyone well so
ask believe receive looks like you got
yourself a boyfriend and we'll be
keeping our eyes peeled until they go IG
official or exchange the L word you know
the one
[Music]